welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's webinar
challenges of cannabis testing in the US
and abroad
presented by Deborah Marin a former
commissioner for Maryland medical
cannabis commission my name is Susie
Valdez and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before you begin I want to
remind everyone that this event is in
our active we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation simply click on that ask a
question box and let us know you're
experiencing the problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of your presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming our presenter
Deborah Marin I will now turn the
presentation over to her welcome Debbie
thank you Susie for that kind
introduction and good morning everyone
I'm delighted to spend the next half
hour or so sharing some of my thoughts
with you about the challenges of
cannabis testing as Suzy mentioned I
have no conflicts of interest I
represent myself as a regulatory
consultant to the medical cannabis
industry and I am a former commissioner
with the Maryland medical cannabis
program
by way of abstract I'd like to introduce
my talk by saying the vast majority of
United States and other countries
require quality control testing cannabis
and cannabis produced products prior to
release for distribution the purpose of
product testing is to provide patients
with the assurance that the medicine is
potent and pure and safe for use
analytical testing also assures that the
contents match the label claim that
there is batch to batch consistency and
the product is potent impure throughout
shelf-life each state and country has
its own set of testing requirements and
regulations for analytical laboratories
with these requirements come challenges
for both the regulators as well as the
regulated industry so if by way of
learning objective today I would expect
that those that are listening will learn
how medical cannabis products are tested
and the quality standards they will also
learn about the regulatory testing
requirements in the US and other
countries and finally will appreciate
the various testing challenges as state
programs grow and evolve
so to get into the meat of the talk I'd
like to first begin by saying what is
the purpose of testing to some it's
self-evident but for most important
points are the fact that we want to
assure of course the products are
protein pure we want to make sure that
the products match the information on
the label claim this is the message to
the patient and to the distributors and
them in dispensaries about what is the
contents of this product we want to
assure consistency from batch to batch
many of these products are used
chronically patients need to have the
absolute assurance that from batch to
batch a lot a lot container to container
are getting the same product and of
course the ever-important potency and
purity throughout shelf-life
so what are some of these general
testing requirements and quality control
essentially 27 out of the 33 states that
have medical programs require QC testing
prior to product release to the
dispensary these laboratories that
perform the testing must be independent
of the grower processor dispensary or by
by any licensed authority to participate
in a state program many states require
that the independent laboratory be
accredited by a third-party accrediting
body quality control begins with
standardization and what this means is
that you don't test quality into a
product it begins with the step 1 which
in this case is the planting of the seed
or the clone and this standardization
precedes all the way through to harvest
to packaging processing and eventually
to the dispensaries
I can't emphasize enough that the
requirements for standardization be be
something that is engineered to through
the entire process as far as testing for
standards we apply the Good
Manufacturing Practices good agriculture
practices and of course has the when
food production is involved and last but
not least within the laboratory itself
quality assurance program and up-to-date
and complete and form FPS will ensure
consistency within the lab with between
operators and day-to-day consistency
so a few definitions that will pertinent
to the rest of the talk obviously
there's many many more definitions but
these two are particularly important to
me what is an approved laboratory
well the approved laboratory is one that
has a facility that has applied for and
received approval whether it be a
approval or just a registration of
license whatever the state requirements
demand and this approval is received to
identify collect handle and conduct
tests on samples from both growers or
cultivators and processors and the
second key definition is what is the
scope of accreditation this is a term
that's used by the accrediting body to
detail the approved list of test methods
with full method validation that the lab
has been accredited to perform based on
whatever state requirements are so in
other words the crediting body does not
actually write the method nor do they
judge the met method for fitness they
they assess the method and they make
sure that this is the method that's
going to be used every single time that
a sample is tested at this accredited
lab so what are some general provisions
that states require when a laboratory
wants to start business first of all as
I previously mentioned the lab must be
approved or registered by the state here
in Maryland we register lab it's an
application process some states actually
have a formal approval process the
regulatory authorities such as the state
Commission will post on their website a
list of all approved labs so that
information is available to the general
public and to the licensees laboratory
personnel including the directors should
be trained and educated most states have
very specific educational and training
requirements at the director level as
well as managers and lab agents labs are
subject to the inspection by state
authority and so that the state retains
or respond with the right to come in at
any time whether it's a
regular routine inspection or a
for-cause inspection one thing that
would allow the states to come in and do
an inspection many states require
proficiency testing in other words
blinded samples are prepared and made
available to the lab for them to conduct
tests to compare against unknown
quantity to give the further assurance
that the state that labs know what
they're doing with regulations at the
state level come penalties for violating
procedures these can range from fine to
injunction and loss of license we need
to think about falsifying reports but we
know that this can happen and if it does
it is certainly something that is
actionable by a state authority and
finally some states will collect field
samples from time to time to also check
on label content and also to check for
purity
so after the laboratory has decided that
they want to go into a business in a
state with a program here are some of
the basic procedural approval steps that
most states have obviously these will
vary from state to state but in general
the submitted application will of course
include the the name and the address of
the owner the name of the director of
the laboratory a copy of the certificate
of accreditation or in case the
accreditation is still in process some
states for example like Maryland have a
provisional period in which the lab is
allowed to get up to speed and complete
the accreditation so in those cases it
would be a contract with an accrediting
body that would suffice a complete list
of the SOPs that the lab will prepare
and use and I highlight sampling
protocol because we're going to spend
some time talking about that later on
very important the list of all the
laboratory equipment a complete
description of all the tests that are
going to be performed going back to that
definition of scope of accreditation a
full and complete description of the
quality assurance program chain of
custody and sample tracking in states
that have track and trace systems this
reaches out to the transfer of sample to
and from laboratories from other life
and holders like the cultivator or the
processor and of course the competency
the employee there their knowledge and
experience and of course in some states
a background check is required as well
so testing requirements as you can
imagine vary from state to state and
this is just a generalized scheme of
what are most commonly seen as the
testing requirements in the states that
I have done work in some states for
example require a written contract with
between the licensee the grower or the
processor and the testing lab some
states require that the grower processor
laboratory results are entered into the
electronic tracking system which is
controlled by the state program
the scope of testing for each plant
harvest and each process product lot
might vary some from state to state but
in general this is QC so you see me that
every lot or every batch of product that
sits on a dispenser shelf has been
tested and released and reads these
specifications so at minimum we have a
list here which are azam of course some
of the purity requirements pesticide
residue if in fact pesticides have been
used in the cultivation of the plant
solvent residues if that is part of the
extraction process of the cannabinoids
and tripping form the plant material
water activity and moisture content
these are vital to make sure that the
plant are the dried flower if that
finished product has adequate shelf-life
and that there isn't enough water that
would support on microbial growth
microbial contaminants such as
pathological bacteria and fungus
aflatoxin and then on the potency side
of course the two main cannabinoid THC
and CBD and most other states expand
that list to include some of the minor
cannabinoids such as the acid forms of
THC and CBD and also cbn and CBC and
some of the others that would have to be
something that would check be checked on
state by state and their various rule
and then terpenes there's a lot of
variability about testing requirements
or terpenes for example in Maryland we
have a list of eight that we require the
labs to test for if in fact they are on
the label and that's that's an important
component if the labeling does not
include a description of terpene by
content or if the levels are below the
level of detection then the requirement
for testing terpene is waived in some
states and this is a very big one an
important one for me is that some states
require stability testing I think this
is an area that we're going to see grow
Maryland does requirement require it now
as of this year they have not been
enforcing that requirement but it is my
understanding
that they will begin to enforce it and
the significance of stability testing is
that a base of data will be built it
will be important not only for the
grower or processor but also for the
state agencies and and actually for the
world at large because there is quite a
dearth of actual shelf life data to
understand how long these cannabinoids
and terpenoids
to the plant product or the finished
product is process
so shifting gears now to the next the
second half of the talk I'd like to talk
about some of the challenges as you can
understand with every program
there's the ideal which I've just gone
through in the first 10 slides but then
there's also reality things are going to
happen both on the side of the
regulators and the side of the regulated
industry and so what I have in the next
few slides is four examples of what I
witnessed and observed as current
challenges in this space we're going to
spend a little time talking about
sampling of a very important topic and
very timely the next challenge is
something I call granulation versus
beautiful bud and I will explain that
inflating THC test result sadly this is
an issue and then finally
misrepresenting total yeast and mold
test results by virtue of using
different analytical techniques for
measurement so let's move to sampling a
sound sampling plan is absolutely vital
to make sure and to assure the best
possible accuracy in the result and that
that result reflects and represents the
whole batch so in other words these this
is a plant this is a plant that's
harvested there will be plant parts that
will be visible they'll be trim they'll
be leaves they'll be sugar leaves
they'll be families and of course
they'll be of the dried flower bud and
all of this is very non-homogeneous and
so collecting a sample of this sort is
difficult and it's difficult to
represent it statistically sound so what
most states have done and I believe
Maryland was the first to recall this is
that the sample not be collected by the
licensee but rather a representative
from the testing lab who is independent
and unbiased will come in and perform
the test perform the sampling excuse me
sometimes the sampling is performed
under video surveillance or at minimum
it is performed in as a witness with
another person witnessing the sampling
as I mentioned the sample must be
representative the whole batch or lot so
there's various ways that a
statistically sound sample can be taken
and if you've got a bin and you've got
plant material in it you can use a see
from a sampling device to go down into
the middle of the bend
besides the top the bottom of the bin
and and collect an aggregate sample that
is as representative as it possibly can
be and in states that require stability
testing and quality assurance samples it
is my advice that those samples all be
collected at the same time the QC sample
is taken so the QA sample is put in
retain for a later use if in fact
there's a recall or there's a a patient
adverse event that to a sample can be
retrieved and used to retest to
reconfirm the product student
specification and of course the
stability sample will be stored in a
control room temperature environment
until the interval at which the testing
is required occurs
so challenge number two
granulation versus the beautiful bud
this somewhat overlaps with the sampling
dilemma as I said when you've got a bin
of harvest to dry flour clearly you can
see you can see flower buds you can see
leaves and one of the one of the issues
one of the one of the remedies for this
um is to actually size the batch and
what do I mean by sizing the batch the
plant material can be put through a
grinder or a sizer with Teflon coated or
otherwise inert chopping blades so that
the sticky material in the trichomes
isn't lost to the blade and the result
then is a much more uniform harvest
batch and so sampling then becomes a
much easier challenge and it really does
reduce drastically the result the chance
for sampling bias the dilemma though
comes in in the fact that in the US and
this is an observation of mine and I
believe of many others there is a
general patient consumer preference to
see an intact well but quite honestly as
an antelope chemist I don't understand
that but I guess this is something that
has become tradition and so it is
largely unacceptable in the u.s. to have
samples in the de century that represent
granulated flower material if that is
the finished product that the patient is
interested
and once again sampling of that non
granulated flour but may not be
representative of a whole batch and has
much more of a chance to have a sampling
bias
so um challenge number three and this
one is a difficult one even to discuss
but I think it's important enough that
we spend a few minutes talking about the
hell and the why that first of all the
hell how can you inflate THC results you
know the lab has procedures we've got
state rules in place for the most part
everybody is accredited it should be a
fail-safe system but here are five and
I'm not saying these happen these are
potentials but here are five potential
ways that I have conceived of can be
ways in which you can subtly influence
THC results toward a higher level first
of all something that I call secondary
sampling so the sampling has been done
at the licensee the sample comes back to
the laboratory absent video surveillance
the lab analysts they're preparing the
sample that is going to be ready for the
instrument and so obviously that entire
sample has been collected is not that
not needed and so secondary sampling if
the product is not granulated can be
potentially biased at this point
secondly a grower can pre-select what
they are going to make available to the
independent animal exemplar before they
even arrive I can't say once again that
I have witnesses or that I know that
this practice has taken place but once
again it is a potential thirdly if the
met if the analytical methods lacked
sufficient validation you could
introduce a bias by virtue of a bad
method
set fourthly something that I call
intentional and subtle delusion errors
what does this need well obviously
instruments are very very sensitive and
so the sample from preparation to
dilution in order to have the proper
concentration for detection and
quantitation will be diluted possibly
several times before it's actually
introduced into the equipment during
that process subtle dilution errors
which could add up could potentially
concentrate the product that is going to
be ejected in the machine and thus you
know an unintentional or intentional
inflation of the TT results could occur
and last and probably most egregious and
I hope I would never experience this but
if data after the analysis is completed
is exported as a text file and is
unprotected from tampering then results
through human intervention could be
changed so the second question then is
why does this occur why why would there
be reason to ever want to inflate T's
the results well the two most
predictable answers that I can think of
our things that I've seen in Maryland
once again and probably in other states
as well and that is for the most part
pricing of the product if it's not
controlled by state rule typically is
based on THC content so the grower sells
to the processor that price from the
grower the processor will be higher
based on the higher level of THC
likewise from the processor to the
dispensary and then ultimately from the
dispensary to the patient and so there
is incentive throughout the entire chain
to
want to present the product with the
maximum amount of THC possible secondly
and I know this is happening in States
especially with states that have rules
about approved conditions that might
allow for some more flexibility in
physician recommendation we have seen
and I have to admit I don't like it but
that there is a recreational component
to medical market and so if you believe
that and if you witness that then it's
understandable that in the recreational
space the higher THC content is
obviously what is more desired
so the last and most interesting I think
challenge that we've seen goes back to
an incident that occurred about a year
or so ago and it regarded the test for
total yeast and mold totally euston mold
is a typical test that is performed on
botanicals plant material medicinal
plant material and the test typically is
it's based on the test that is published
in the American urban pharmacopoeia
monograph and that monograph is based on
the standardized methods from the
bacteriological analytical manual and
typically what is recognized even to
this day is what is known as you know
traditional plate counting on auger
plate so that is that that is the
recognized standard at this point in
time but with the advent of PCR testing
PCR standing for polymerase chain
reaction testing it is a very it's a
very quantitative method it's very
precise it's very accurate but it does
have some reservations at this point in
time in my opinion
the test is valid for species specific
organisms such as Salmonella and e-coli
so what does that mean in a total used
mold test basically what you're
measuring is any fungal species so we
know that there are thousands and
thousands of those unless there is a
primer which is the equivalent of a
standard for these species the PCR test
in my opinion at this point in time is
not completely valid thirdly the PCR has
the potential to measure both live and
dead DNA of the organism and that can
influence the accuracy of the result and
at this point in time the baam the
biological analytical man manual does
not consider as a valid test for either
total yeast mold or total aerobic counts
so an interesting study was conducted in
Nevada this goes back I believe in 1900
2017 and they were having issues and
these issues were coming to the
attention of the state by various labs
so the state decided to conduct a very
interesting study and in this study the
state collected 41 sample of cannabis
flour these samples were subjected to
testing by both the traditional plating
method as I previously described as well
as the PCR technique
specification which is generally
recognized and is included in the HP
monograph is a respective occasion of
less than 10,000 colony forming units so
the samples were prepared for plating
based on the baam method and for the PCR
technique of the samples were prepared
based on manufacturer's directions
so the results that came out of this was
very interesting 16 of the 41 samples
passed by both techniques but more
importantly 20 of the 41 so basically
half tailed by plating but then most
surprisingly three of the 41 only three
of the 41 failed by the PCR test so what
did the state conclude from this study
basically that the PCR technique
generated on the average of a result of
an 85 percent false positive rate and
that the PCR test therefore was not
considered valid and as a consequence
the state of nevada has now banned the
PCR as a technique for measuring either
total yeast enrolled or total Rove
account until such time as the mecca can
be fully validated by a recognized
authorities such as the ASAC or ASTM or
or some other testing organizations that
performs this kind of work and another
conclusion that came out of this test
from nevada was that state said came on
board downstream such as california took
a look at this and said well you know
what's really important it is what is
pathogenic to humans and so California
opted to drop the test altogether in
favor of species specific pathogenic
tests with limits such as we mentioned
like Salmonella and e-coli so that that
really was a very important study and I
believe that other shades come on board
they will be taking a look at this and
at some point in time I would hope to
see the PCR test become the recognized
standard as we advanced science
so now for the remaining time and the
remaining slides that I have I'm going
to shift gears and talk very briefly
about some key international markets
these are places where we know they have
national laws and I'm referring mostly
now to just medical youth and so let me
start with requirements in Canada as we
all know candidate has had a sea change
with the update and last fall with the
inclusion of adult use as a national law
but they also revised many many of their
medical regulations and so in 2018 the
congratulations for all testing both
adult youth and for medical youth were
revised to require that each batch or
each lot of products must be tested
plain and simple the requirements
include that are not limited to potency
meaning THC and CBD content and purity
testing for things like heavy metals
pesticide residue and microbiological
contaminants the the Health Canada
recognizes 21 permitted pesticides that
are allowed to be used and the cal
canada authorities will conduct random
testing from time to time on products to
make sure that these pesticides if they
are present if they are being used do
not exceed the tolerance limits that
Health Canada has established and
finally while Health Canada does not
accredit testing labs they do license
them and at the time that I published
this presentation I believe the work
upward of 52 licensed laboratories in
the country
moving on to the Netherlands a country
that I particularly admire and I have
done a lot of studying there the
Netherlands have had medical youth as a
national law for a long time they have
absolutely perfected the process of
growing processing in a standardized way
and likewise they have a very very
thorough and strict efficient testing
program so under the office of medicinal
cannabis in the Netherlands the rigors
requirement that each lot and these
batch of product once again be tested
and the testing is done by an
independent lab contracted with by the
Dutch government and I believe that
company is known as Pharma leaves and
requirements in the Netherlands once
again are what you would consider
standards potency water content loss on
drying heavy metals pesticide residue
absent microbiological contaminants and
also appearance the one thing I will add
to about requirements in the Netherlands
is that potency has very tight
specifications around of the label claim
so in other words if if the dried flower
is the finished product and the dry
flower is purported to have ten percent
THC the specifications in the
Netherlands are plus or minus 10 percent
label claims so a range around that 10
would be of course 9 to 11 percent and
those those strict criteria are what
would be equivalent to what you would
see was it with a approved drug product
and so you can see they're very specific
very strict and part of the reason for
this is the years and years of
experience of growing in a standardized
way and perfecting analytical techniques
that they are able to impose these kind
of strict specifications and and I would
say that this is a direction that all
testing programs should be headed
towards some day
moving on to my final country which is
Australia obviously there are many many
more countries that have national laws
and testing requirements but I wanted to
just highlight Australia because they
have a program that I linked off the
ground and growing very rapidly and
under the Therapeutic Goods
Administration therapeutic good order 93
requires once again that each badge each
lot of product is tested and this
includes product that is exported to
exported to other countries and also
product that is imported from other
countries nothing sits on a dispensary
shelf or a pharmacy shelf in Australia
that hasn't been tested and released so
what does Australia rely on as far as
standard basically what they have done
is to adopt Parrs portions of the
European pharmacopoeia just like we have
in the u.s. with the HP monograph for
standardized procedures for things like
residual solvents and heavy metals
and also preparation and for extracts at
dry product based on medicinal herbal
products required in Australia are of
course potency testing and here you can
see I haven't ruined the specifications
slightly different from what I've just
described in the Netherlands for flour
the range is a little more liberal so in
other words if you're between 80 and 120
percent of that label claim so going
back to the example of a 10 milligram
all right excuse me a 10 percent THC
content in Australia potency would pass
if it ranked between 8 and 12 percent
however for dosage forms which obviously
have been processed from the flour and
extracted and formulated into
traditional dosage form Australian men
reverts back to the traditional ninety
two hundred and ten percent label claim
so I think this is a very fair approach
and I would expect is that this matures
and standardization of the whole process
and food that once again to Australia
will tighten up the range around potency
for dried flower Australia also requires
that heavy metal testing and pesticide
residue microbial contamination and also
an appearance test which would include
foreign matter and a test for total ash
so I'm going to wrap up my talk now with
what is next what is in the future
this industry is rapidly evolving I
don't even think it's evolving I think
it's revolving at the speed at which
everything is changing not just in the
marketplace in the regulatory
environment but also in the testing
space we know there are many
organizations right now including the
United States Pharmacopeia the European
pharmacopoeia and other private
organizations such as I previously
mentioned AOA C the American Chemical
Society ASTM are all currently very very
involved in working on drafting on
national and international standards for
some of the tests that we've talked
about today I look forward to this I
think this is a largely positive
development to have one standards it
will help the industry it will help the
custom labs
it will help regulators it will help
everybody to have one standards and a
standard isn't static a standard is
something that is basically as good as
it is until the science and the
technology grows and we know that will
always continue and so the standards are
meant to be reviewed from time to time
on a periodic basis to look at currency
versus you know the state of the art and
the state of the science I think we're
going to see much more enforcement and
requirements for compliance at the state
level many of these state programs like
Maryland are just getting through their
initial year or two of operation and so
the states now have a chance to sort of
refine and get more involved in
enforcement and inspection requirements
so that some of the challenges that I've
mentioned earlier maybe won't the
challenges at some point in time and and
there will be a good symbiosis between
the regulated and the regulatory and
finally I think that we've seen it
already some of the accrediting body
some of these
independent for profit or not-for-profit
accreditation bodies are beginning to
partner with groups and including state
regulatory bodies to make the
accreditation product process more
cannabis specific and so that it will
just make the accreditation even more
meaningful than it is right now so with
that I thank you very much for your kind
attention and I will be delighted to
respond to any questions you have by
email on my talk my presentation and any
aspect of testing regulations this is
something that I am very passionate
about and I hope that you have benefited
from this talk today and have learned
something at least enough to to forward
some important questions to me that I
will be happy to answer and so with that
I will sign off and what we turn this
portion of the talk back to Susie thank
you again
and Thank You Debbie for that
informative presentation I'd also like
to thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that this
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through June 2019 as a final
reminder Debbie will follow up with any
questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now and thank you for
joining us we'll see you next time bye
bye